[Musique]
grandiose
historique à refaire classique
les livres étaient magnifiques ils
étaient de toutes tailles c'était très
joli différentes époques comment le
bâtiment évoluer comment a-t-il été
transformé etc au gré de l'histoire
justement et c'est ça qui est également
passionnant parce que c'est une sorte de
machine à remonter le temps quand on
pénètre dans l'hémicycle du Sénat on est
un petit peu saisi on a presque
l'impression de de croiser les ombres de
Victor Hugo etc
c'est toujours c'est amusant à voir j'ai
vu la chambre de la reine des mystique
ça fait plaisir de visiter un lieu comme
ça et ça nous rappelle qu'on est dans un
pays qui a beaucoup de culture et qui
donne beaucoup de l'émotion finalement
la bibliothèque
en fait il y a pas de deux salles qui
ont la même le même style
vous pouvez autant
historique qui remonte et qui retrace
toute l'histoire de la France depuis
Charlemagne jusqu'à Saint Louis était
vraiment des spatules et des portraits
de chacun des grands hommes qui ont
marqué l'histoire de la France dans
chaque pièce du Sénat c'était une grand
un grand plaisir de venir enfin visiter
le Sénat de le découvrir cet
environnement l'hémicycle dans lequel
travaille nos sénateurs moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'annexe de la
bibliothèque et la bibliothèque bien sûr
bonjour à tous
général signe de paix et il dit je
réfléchis avant de faire valoir
[Musique]